dr. Gao is vice president at the Center
for China and globalization he joins us
now live from London good to have you
with us Victor China has been widely
criticised at least over its initial
handling of the the virus outbreak are
those criticisms valid no I would say
that China is now faced with this very
massive public health crisis and we need
to do whatever we can to fight against
the corona virus and put the whole
crisis behind us of course in the first
face leading all the way to generate the
twenties lots of mistakes were made by
different levels in the government
hierarchy and precious time was lost and
this added to the magnitude of this
crisis to start with but I think ever
since January the twenties China is on
the right track and the whole countries
be mobilised to do whatever it needs to
be done to fight against the corona
virus and we are doing whatever we can
to put this crisis behind us and also
please allow me to express my
condolences for more than 1,000 Chinese
nationals who have passed away because
of the contamination with this corona
virus and also please allow me to
express my solidarity and full support
to all those heroes who are now fighting
in the front line against the corona
virus they include not only nurses
doctors etc but also lots of other
people who take a lot of risk in
fighting against this corona virus China
cannot afford to lose this battle we
have to win this battle against the
corona virus you talk about the
mishandling of the situation by local
officials at least in the early days of
the the crisis why aren't people further
up the power chain in China taking
responsibility why have there only been
sackings at local level I think
eventually there will be a day when
there will be a very detailed chronology
being written out and responsibilities
being checked out for example we can do
that another day rather than in the
middle of this fight against the corona
a virus I think the local government
officials wasted a lot of time they were
a very dangerous ground because this
coronavirus or something new even today
we do not have all the scientific
knowledge above the corona virus so they
probably thought that they should move
forward more cautiously they need to
really wait until further instructions
from Beijing for example however now we
know that in facing with this kind of
corona virus not a single minute should
be wasted and every minute should be
seen sting fighting against this virus
Victor how do you answer the criticism
the Chinese government is as far as some
people are concerned more concerned
about restricting the spread of
information about the virus than it is
about tackling the virus itself that's
untrue I think if anyone with the
decency of the mind with the objectivity
of his mind looking at what China is
doing for example imposing quarantine
not only a Wuhan city with a population
of 12 million people but more or less on
the whole province of Hebei province
which has a population of 6 billion
people and then if you look at many
other cities who voluntarily impose
quarantine and restrict the movement of
the people you will see that we are
really leaving no stones unturned in the
fight against this coronavirus I think
this demonstrates that China's really
put a premium on human lives we cannot
afford to lose this battle against
coronavirus all the others are secondary
fighting against the coronavirus winning
this war is the most important thing now
and finally Victor on Thursday we saw
that revision e-excuse me of infection
rates and death rates due to a different
way of of confirming whether someone
actually has the virus China's claims to
be being completely open and honest
about the infection and death rates
credible I think ever since the second
phase started on January the 20th I
think the government agencies throughout
China at different levels of the
government
hierarchy are doing their best to come
up with disclosure full disclosure and
this is very important in fighting
against the coronavirus now the way how
the contraction is defined is a very
much of a medical and scientific way and
I think the day before yesterday the
huge boost in the number of contracted
cases is a reflection of using a more
pragmatic way to define contracted rate
and I think this will actually put more
people who may have suspicious symptoms
are being included in the contraction
rate this is actually good for all of us
because we will know how many people are
being contracted and this will have the
medical personnel on the ground and in
other parts of China to do a better job
in fighting against this coronavirus I'm
good Japanese to win this war many
thanks indeed victor go thank you very
much for having me